yeah baby it's a boy psychobabble and
we're [ __ ] going 25,000 miles an hour
we're about to go to the I say caverns I
hope you already [ __ ] [ __ ] why would he
crash getting sanity
I think it's out right here I'm talking
driving over there cuz actually quite a
bit
no I got my cow down vodka like this I
like that the footstep for oh it always
stays there that's cool for something I
got my cap
as kids about hey let's cattle say that
what's in here
luckily he had the coat to protect him
from the biting cold
[ __ ] I mean they have that these damn
things
Fox over here
Carl scout training was very deep in his
memory you gotta get again to start a
fire
at first sucking down at all any [ __ ]
logs yeah I've gotta be [ __ ] kidding
me
[ __ ] wet out here let's take a piece
of wet here I didn't know what a [ __ ]
oh my god down here
you gotta be [ __ ] [ __ ] me you
gotta be [ __ ] me oh my god it takes
ten years I walk in this guy I just
I'm out
now I got one piece of white I better
[ __ ] it up I'm sorry adapt you can damn
it that's God all right son you everyone
yeah that's our my are together
again we're back we're back [ __ ] a nice
a camera is it bad
like [ __ ] light
Hey oh that [ __ ] a woof there sound
take out that bad boys
is that here already I got ya
over here [ __ ] wolf down like
straight down [ __ ] honey now when I go
there sit down with us
my [ __ ] hammer taking a hammer out
for this one a hatchet are you [ __ ]
right here
[ __ ] is this
okay my [ __ ] headache again another
instance of this magic ice what was this
one doing lying on the ground I see
mustache
he had been running in fear from
something creeping towards him against
which he couldn't do anything only to
end up like this sandwich
it seemed as though Raisa had been ready
to take up arms and slay people like
Hamilton could he have committed murder
for his cause who could have gotten
killed in front of his very eyes
that's a lot like a good essay it's all
I gotta say
oh [ __ ] how am i [ __ ] things up
so that's how you get up
make sure I know how to get that
Carl like many of his contemporaries
felt like he had more trouble breathing
when he wasn't smoking cigarette was his
own personal breathing is alright we're
down pretty good
we're they're pretty good
are also really felt observable all
right
that really yeah that took like two
seconds
[ __ ] waste my time with them away
okay see dead bodies sick [ __ ] this
off
I said I did not feel hurt
taking out my other guy
nice seem to take over this place like
mold that wall wasn't there earlier how
was he going to get out of here Oh get
the [ __ ] out of here
shut the [ __ ] anymore the [ __ ] the ice
pod Lee did not budge despite the
powerful fiery blast something was
definitely wrong in this place
you have got to be [ __ ] me
thank you so God either the other way
that
[ __ ] blop here
as if there is let's do this
that's right yeah yeah
[ __ ] out here
that worked great
no stole and withstand the force of
dynamite
where the [ __ ] this is
like I was little animation so friendly
it's so nice because then they know that
I doing once hi
sighs looking for my car
I can love tracks out here
I can't I guess there's nowhere else
together except that area
I'd say
a sexy
okay
okay
nice [ __ ]
I don't know let's say okay we're going
back up to the ice wall cuz I don't know
what the [ __ ] else there is so [ __ ] it
yes
make this [ __ ] shirt back ah [ __ ] see
I don't get that either
every time we [ __ ] hit something you
get [ __ ] up
like you [ __ ] san diego's up the guys
like a [ __ ] mass against me
I got I got some [ __ ] gloves now
gasps
that's a dime
I get set hey [ __ ] you says [ __ ] I swap
okay my bar this is that are we sure I
got [ __ ] wood in here now [ __ ] huh
[ __ ] here
[ __ ]
I gotta [ __ ] tag virus wait get some
[ __ ] flyers
okay
I guess we know where our phrase that
[ __ ] okay cuz I can through here if
honestly I can't go through this wall I
don't know what the [ __ ] I tell you oh
my god hello sir
Carl had no issue recognizing this
spirit like bigger but he couldn't
figure out what they wanted from him the
Phantom freed of reality's shackles
vanished in the forest
Carl another phantom disappeared in the
wilderness Carl had seen what happened
to it - yes I heard phantom gently faded
away and a fourth one Carl noticed that
as the cursed villagers finally left
reality he could feel a sense of
unburdening exuding from that [ __ ]
stars how that's God come on who is this
I don't know what I'm [ __ ] go sir
what's that one [ __ ]
I can sense that the cold was beating a
retreat as if he was moving away from
some kind of center of gravity an
African satisfied was that
I [ __ ] know who that is
at the d'harans yet what the [ __ ]
wait [ __ ] that is oh yeah it's a man the
further Carl moved away from the ice we
let our senses give back to it finding
it's the last one that girl loves her
house actually one must have dropped
this in a hurry
yeah probably whoever did was heading
into the woods Carl's tracking instincts
were quickly kicking in hey snap Ernest
there's a body wave [ __ ] it out there
yeah
that's it I'm not really sure what the
[ __ ] we went to
I know it's past a little [ __ ] [ __ ]
Joe [ __ ] garage thing [ __ ] gas
[ __ ] you know that [ __ ] ass what the
[ __ ]
and uh uh [ __ ] you fast [ __ ]
gotta find all the [ __ ] president
POTUS
[ __ ] [ __ ] away too fast are all felt at
the store and its surrounding still I
can't that's a left kind of
all right
I'm hoping around here [ __ ] mystery
so up at the left
like somehow yeah
it said that there was like a [ __ ]
yeah I never go to the pine everyone too
far back spot
yes I think I went over
again letting screens
I don't think I want over there
whatever the [ __ ] that is
see if the [ __ ] is that
the cave I never went to the [ __ ]
cave
[ __ ]
[ __ ] is this
yeah as I call off our waste of time
like a secret projects a down there
fuckin'-a there you know all the way
[ __ ] there I remember them being a
secret product that [ __ ] that way over
there - [ __ ]
yeah I went to that cabin already I
never went the secret project
there
I think he was like adding it in
I don't have to go all the way [ __ ]
over there and I got a dammit you gotta
tell you know you got to make it
laughing call that here where's my guy
yes
a long way to go
[ __ ]
I guess you have faster you're [ __ ]
sweet down this
and then get fair cards all I gotta say
that's just about what a crazy [ __ ]
game
or play along doc has pretty good
you know that secret [ __ ] scientist
are all felt at the store and its
surrounding still held their secrets and
he didn't like to miss out for me
all the way I'm [ __ ] in on this
Hey
he's got here [ __ ] forever
[ __ ] out of here and sava Carson so much
now your tips gonna be my eyes best
every curse plan is a dollar
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
as they had
[ __ ] is that look at that glowing set
nice eh
[Music]
all right that's all that
so this last episode [ __ ] fragmented
it's [ __ ]
where the [ __ ] I am right now I don't
know where the [ __ ] I right now
right at that [ __ ] end
I do it
in the [ __ ]
the garage guy
[ __ ] yeah it's the garage guy the secret
lab
this makes a lot of [ __ ] sense right
now
and I just [ __ ] drive off the No
[ __ ] it we're walking it
because I'm not gonna [ __ ] build [ __ ]
never thought he would be dancing with
the wool I popped that [ __ ]
take a lime over there holy [ __ ] those
[ __ ] fast
[ __ ]
Carl Scout training was buried deep in
his memory what do you need again to
start
you have got to be [ __ ] kidding me
get a crowbar
what father yeah
they can't go
[ __ ] loading
I got lighting
Aurel hadn't lived up this good finder
reputation he still hadn't found any of
the wealth contained into much like okay
so apparently now I gotta go fight that
[ __ ] okay
oh [ __ ] it back to the store apparently
this [ __ ] [ __ ] game this game
has turned this game has gone from like
super the [ __ ] like [ __ ] hard so
it was like all right it was like no big
deal I was like all right like you know
you need to find a mic you can probably
find out multiple houses now this game
has got to [ __ ] like if you need an
item it's all look at it in one spot in
all of [ __ ] Canada good luck you know
yeah like we got some gloves now go [ __ ]
yourself you know like they kept me in
this house it could be in that house
like you know outside it's just nowhere
you know [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
okay so I did a little digging now my
fine where the [ __ ] crowbar is cuz
honestly it's just not fun to watch we
just [ __ ] flaunt around here for ten
hours yeah I know it's not fun for you
guys you know okay so the crowbar is
supposedly at the garage oh the general
store oh [ __ ]
I can get it rock quick we can continue
on our journey
because at this point I'm kind if I
could get by this game I thought that
just trying to get the [ __ ] by this game
okay okay okay there's the [ __ ]
garage factory get in it now all right
that I heard there's no I heard us the
crowbar was stuck under the lift yeah
[ __ ] a suspending Carl's imposing
stature car-lifting wasn't part of this
skill set yeah I know
oh yeah I guess thought that I
all right scepter setting this up as I
turn it back up
that supposedly there should be
electricity in here now a fire can't be
started with the snap of the fingers I
can't even pick up the crowbar then
staring intently at the controls won't
be enough to make that lift budge the
poor thing was out of power the [ __ ] are
you talking about okay paws up
get your [ __ ] off deposit
a lot of [ __ ] here fine apne right one
firestarter though I need this Lantern
it's 90 so many [ __ ] followers
I have any other fire starters
yeah [ __ ] dark in there I said it
right general day is going
they're [ __ ] main switcher me or
something
staring intently at the controls won't
be enough the poor thing was out of
power
see this is the [ __ ] [ __ ]
where's the [ __ ] place getting power
[ __ ] dirtbags
that's the wire right looks pretty
healthy to me
pretty [ __ ] happening
I just flicker in there
it's a lot of [ __ ] that lit up for it
the note explained that the garage and
the store couldn't be supplied with
electricity a star sucking off the
garage is on
a power line
there's like different settings the [ __ ]
no generator
thank ya there should be no [ __ ]
those shoes now got the generator yeah
oh my god okay here we go the [ __ ] up
here at long last the crowbar was within
Carl's grass surely it would come in
handy at some point charlie wow I really
liked it all those sounds was shot okay
alright I guess our [ __ ] going back
I just love driving I gotta walk in
simulators what this has Shattuck all
right let's do this
far off help at the store and its
surrounding student 30 times
three [ __ ] times
the end
when I said that wolf like [ __ ] eighty
feet
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I can Canada [ __ ]
Canada oh my god
back in Canada
why
I had like this
so-called
oh my god
Thank You [ __ ] texting me
[ __ ]
where they I got
light light out okay don't have wood
[ __ ] wood
anyone freeze up what that's bad
oh my god good take 10 years
I wish I got snowmobile now hey get
right
running supposed to keeping a warm brown
irani is about you a lot
guess I'll run over here Lois Steve I
guess
seems a lot last day but you know right
now second out of breath like two
seconds better fit right make me run you
hold the [ __ ] flashlight up
and I can't right now that we're getting
there oh my god it takes ten years
oh my god
shut up
there's a [ __ ] hamster
that noise
I'm not gonna reading that [ __ ] is this
safe
okay
that large antenna in the middle of the
path undoubtedly ideal in attempting to
communicate with little green men was
quite awkwardly place there had to be a
lever to control it maybe behind it
Carl would have to figure out how to
reach it yeah okay
yeah Carl yeah man you got a lot of work
today that comes in here
I guess not because I walk around it
because it's alright yeah [ __ ] at the
electric terminals appeared to be linked
together but for what purpose
seems like a puzzle for Meg
okay that's a
allows good
this yells bad I want to do blue and red
right this bad too
red is good
[ __ ]
yellow rat
it always was we just say yellow bread
he's gonna keep the circuit is [ __ ]
good
holy [ __ ] this is confusing
okay so I can't use right - that's
[ __ ] broken he's yellow
yeah I can use yellow
it's grand
I can't he's great
because red
he's grand
well
you had [ __ ] [ __ ] do I do this then
I figure out the future
see what the [ __ ] over here
you know I cannot okay look stay get us
off this [ __ ] puzzle Tina have looked
[ __ ] heat is this jeans
okay let me see what's actually in
[ __ ] abhorrent need all these guys
channeling dr. C otherwise there's no
work
now it really has blue well
caryl rejoiced at the unexpected source
of heat but not as much as his freezing
hands
okay so this has to be negative over
that blue
now it's gonna read
this has to be negative now yellow this
yellow [ __ ] way yeah
now we got crane you know this crane
goes all over [ __ ] way over [ __ ]
shut [ __ ] is it going
Holly [ __ ]
[ __ ] mess oh right here for the [ __ ]
bizarreness [ __ ]
Open Sesame
so that's where the generator keep us
fighting all that was left was to use it
at last so big an effort burn also tiny
piece of my god [ __ ] what else like
[ __ ] missing
you know I'm going to get to
I get to the heat again before I look at
this map [ __ ] freezin here
I got
all right what else already hit that ice
cave yeah
hey about sir
[ __ ] is that
I think it's a tech segment know how it
is but they should cut it out okay let's
see what [ __ ] else we have here
oh just looking at it
okay
that's a [ __ ] aid gasoline the [ __ ]
all of the [ __ ] places are all
deducted this was a map of the area with
those pins pointing to places of
interest now
I did get out guys all right
yes
[Music]